hey everyone I'm Abby sharp from Abby's
kitchen here's a question for you when
unexpected guests show up at your door
where are you gonna try to whip up on
the fly
ramen tuna teriyaki sauce guess this is
gonna work you know do not succumb to
the stresses of the surprise attack
dinner guests and let them ruin your
dinner party a game today I'm back with
round 2 of my kitchen staples miniseries
with two more awesome ingredients to
impress even the sneakiest of guests
coconut products like coconut flour have
become a real hot replacement for
traditional wheat these days because
their Paleo approved naturally
gluten-free and pack fiber protein
insulin called medium-chain fatty acids
which research suggests offer more
unique health properties compared to
other saturated fats islands align by
Earth's choice because they're certified
organic sustainable really delicious and
come in at about half the price of most
of the other brands out there you can
keep a bag of this in the pantry for
about a year here's some great ways you
can use it try making some tropical
themed chicken fingers by dredging your
chicken and coconut flour and eggs
before rolling it in some unsweetened
shredded coconut
whip up some healthier aloe hot pancakes
with a few simple swaps I modify the
recipe by substituting a third of a cup
of coconut flour for each cup of regular
flour adding an extra egg and ensuring
that the liquid to flour ratio is one to
one you can make it even more tropical
by adding some fresh fruit like bananas
mango or pineapple and finish it off
with some coconut chips and why not
finish things off with some decadent
brownies you can take any brownie recipe
and apply those same conversion factors
for a twist on an old favorite
for some weird reason people seem to
think that capers are like some kind of
seafood guys this is not seafood this is
a pickled flower bud a flower just cuz
they're salty and briny and pungent
doesn't make them a seafood but they are
delicious
these guys will last about two years in
the pantry before opening or about a
year in the fridge after opening but
here's some great ways you can use them
double up on your capers in your tomato
sauce for a big boost of briny flavor so
that you can cut back on higher calorie
and pricey olives in your pasta
Puttanesca for a fun take on salsa verde
blend capers with garlic herbs lemon
anchovies and olive oil and serve over
grilled flank steak cut back on the salt
and your salad dressing and pan fry
those little suckers and some olive oil
for a minute until crispy for adding a
light crunch to any salad
see you've got this with these hot new
kitchen staples your in-laws neighbors
even that weird guy that's just eyes you
on Facebook they're all gonna be
completely blown away by your effortless
culinary grace thanks so much for tuning
in
be sure to subscribe to my channel and
I'll see you next time on Abby's kitchen
happy nutrition Bonz
this month's theme is all about eating
well from 9 to 5 so today I'm zoning in
on commuter cravings